bonjour katia lors quels sont les enjeux
de cette nouvelle journée eh bien
c'était la journée des plaidoiries des
avocats des parties civiles jeudi
c'était parce qu'elle vient de se finir
à l'instant avec un fait notable
l'expulsion du principal accusé dans
vous parliez ali riza polak qui se
plaint de séquelles du coc vide
il se dit atteints de vomissements il a
quitté la salle plusieurs fois il s'est
même allongé dans le box il a été très
véhément une attitude jugée
perturbatrice par le président qui l'a
donc fait sortir de la salle pour en
revenir aux plaidoiries des avocats des
parties civiles il y en aura 70 ans tous
alors certains parmi les avocats fustige
le comportement des accusés en ciment
qu'ils mentent et qu'il dissimule et
qu'ils laissent les victimes avec
davantage de questions que de re que de
réponses
et comment se reconstruire dans ce
contexte et puis il estime que les
accusés ne pouvait pas ne pas connaître
ne pas comprendre les intentions et
l'idéologie dame edith coulibaly parce
qu'il le fréquentaient tous les jours
alors je vous propose d'écouter deux
avocats qui ont plaidé cet après midi
catherine aux marques et benjamin ces
dons alors ce qui était important
c'était déjà 2 de décrire leur situation
je pense que c'est important de dire que
et c'est ce que j'ai dit elle n'était
pas venue participer à un bal des
accessoires où il y aurait des victimes
accessoires d'un côté et des accusés
accessoires de l'autre sous prétexte que
les accusés qui sont dans le box ce sont
patients se sont pas eux qui ont tué
pris en otage et menacer les victimes
dans l'arbre des causes que j'ai exposé
il y a tous les actes qui sont reprochés
aux accusés et qui ont permis à
l'attentât d'être comique sans les armes
sans les gilets tactiques sans les
couteaux
sans les explosifs sans les véhicules
sans l'argent sans les escroqueries qui
ont pu permettre d'obtenir de l'argent
et acheter le matériel
il n'ya pas d'attentats dans le monde de
la délinquance
ce qui est mis en exergue ses les mois
de détention les années de détention
pour des petites infractions
là on est sur une grosse infraction une
personne qui a été détenu pendant des
années qui est respecté et personne ne
savait ce qu'il allait commettre c'est
impossible c'est impossible
et en tout cas tous les accusés ont
déposé à la barre
visant à scinder le monde de la
délinquance et le terrorisme
alors que ce sont les jeux les 10 dans
la plaidoirie les deux faces d'une même
pièce sans délinquance
il n'y a pas de terrorisme
quand les avocats ont parlé de
terrorisme de salafisme de liberté
d'expression mais n'ont pas manqué de
détailler cette souffrance immense
immense incommensurable qu'endurent
encore les parties civiles aujourd'hui
merci catia pour toutes ces précisions